hello and welcome to deep dive the
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophies strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning in this episode i sit down
with dan murray certa dan is co-founder
of smart supplement brand heights host
of the uk's top business podcast secret
leaders the co-founder of founders a
writer at forbes covering uk
entrepreneurship and communities and an
angel investor as well in our
conversation dan talks openly about how
his mental health journey led him to
founding heights and we discussed the
relationship between anxiety and
entrepreneurship we also chat about
everything from spiritual enlightenment
to identifying your wants and halves in
life integrity contribution and
i mean like ultimately impact is the the
for me
the key of where i want to see my life's
work go so please feel free to grab a
cup of tea and enjoy the conversation
dan welcome to the podcast how you doing
i'm great ellie thanks for having me
thank you thanks for coming on so uh
you're the founder of the heights
company um what is what is heights oh
straight into it and every question and
how did you how did you talk me into
subscribing yeah
yeah okay so i mean look you're a
productivity expert for starters right
that's your jam and you're looking
allegedly um if the stories are to be
believed and
one of the ways you know one of the uh
most overlooked ways for optimizing
brain performance full stop is nutrition
and
um i guess like to go back to the start
a little bit
um the role that nutrition can play in
our brains is something that is a
you know not particularly uh
necessarily an interesting story to most
not the kind of thing that most people
come across in general i think when
people are looking for your content and
the type of stuff that you
you share on social particularly um you
know it is all about how to get the best
out of life coming from a good base
right so coming from a healthy base i
discovered nutrition um with regards to
brain optimization mental health and
what we call brain care from a low base
so i never had any interest in this
space whatsoever i'm not a
neuroscientist not a nutritionist um but
i had insomnia and i got insomnia out of
nowhere i was perfectly healthy i was
happy um
everything was going well in my life and
then one day i just couldn't sleep and
the next day i couldn't sleep and this
just went on and on and on my anxiety
i've always had some anxiety because i'm
my joke to people but i think it's true
is i'm an entrepreneur um that's like a
career choice of anxiety okay because if
you think about it um anxiety is really
a fixation on thinking about the future
that uncertainty of what might come
um that's a very you know practical
reality of when people describe anxiety
that's what entrepreneurship is you're
constantly creating a future that
doesn't yet exist so you are living in
the future and if you're not you're not
doing it right so they're kind of good
bedfellows so um you know i'd had normal
anxiety and what i call normal anxiety
you know it can be um frustrating a bit
debilitating etc of course and makes you
feel not great and different people have
different symptoms from the anxiety i
have shortness of breath for example
that's my symptom um but this was
chronic anxiety so i'd never had
something like that before um um you
know the symptoms of that were uh you
know i would get hot and cold sweats you
know i would break out into a panic
attack you know these were things that
um were happening to me on a near daily
basis after two to three months of no
sleep and i ended up with insomnia for
six months
um i tried everything i tried calm i
tried sleeping i tried cbt i tried you
know cutting out alcohol having more
alcohol you name it um and i went to a
doctor he gave me sleeping pills
at no point ever did nutrition come up
in the conversation and i went for
dinner with a friend and she said um
have you heard of brain nutrition and i
was like nope literally no idea what
you're talking about that sounds super
weird she's like have you been see a
dietician it's like no what is a
dietitian um which is ridiculous because
actually you know i'm really into health
and wellness um and i was and i used to
work in tech but i was into health and
wellness but i still had no idea what a
dietitian was because i just heard of
nutritionists she was like well it's
like a nutritionist but they deal with
sick people you have a mental health
problem and i was like well i wouldn't
go that far calm down it was quite quite
um offensive almost right i took a bit
of it took a bit of a offense to her
saying that and she was like but you do
you just told me haven't slept for six
months and sound healthy and i was like
oh this is really actually very helpful
framing i hadn't really thought about it
she was like yeah you have insomnia i
hadn't labeled it right i was just like
i'm not sleeping she was like anyway
just go to a dietitian to see what she
says and i did
and she diagnosed me in seconds um told
me to
start taking supplements immediately she
was like she prescribed me supplements
which i thought was a super weird thing
to do because you prescribed medication
not supplements
huge supplement skeptic over here never
taken them before
think they don't work
heard bad things just not particularly
you know taking protein for example so
not like anti-all supplements but you
know for whatever reason in my head just
didn't buy into any of it anyway she
prescribed me dha omega-3 b vitamin
complex and blueberry extract
very specific so you can't go to boots
you can't go to holland barrett you have
to go to like a whole foods or a planet
organic where they basically get the
most expensive highest quality blah blah
blah i thought she was like a
shareholder or something so that's a bit
weird like telling me where to buy my
things but okay spent over a hundred
pounds on those three
um spent a week literally well within
two days i started to like have my first
few hours of sleep within a week i was
sleeping till seven a.m
eight am called her up to tell her what
genius she was and frankly she was just
like this is science this is my job this
is like you told me your symptoms i knew
basically what was wrong also because
i'd eliminated other things right i had
tried the psychological interventions of
my symptoms of insomnia and anxiety
right i'd been to a therapist i'd been
to a sleep therapist i tried lots of
different things so it was easier for
her to say look there's none of those
things it's going to be nutrition you've
got poor brain nutrition you need to
bring it back to a level and this is
where my journey started which was this
like sheer fascination that there is
something so obvious for a scientific
medically trained professional um that
most people do not go to um for her it
was like a one minute fix and i'd spent
six months
basically having my life ruined the
worst thing that i'd ever experienced
and i've had depression and a bunch of
other mental health problems but this
was the worst because it was a daily
lethargy like daily i just couldn't
function which is not a good place to be
for an entrepreneur
and grumpy and snappy with people
because of it anyway like i i just found
this whole thing so crazy that there was
this thing in science
that was so obvious that she knew would
cure me and did
that is a space that people are highly
skeptical about and don't trust and as
an entrepreneur you're like juices start
flowing right or like there is an
amazing opportunity here to combine like
science and evidence alongside really
great communication and brands so this
is kind of where the the backstory of
that started interesting
yeah so i think the the first time we
spoke i think i i said to you when when
i i learned about heights and saw that
it was it was a supplement i kind of
said to you that well supplement equals
scam in my book um
i guess
it sounds it sounds like that was your
opinion of supplements as well before
before this worked for you um
yeah why
why are supplements so associated with
the word scam in like the minds of
normal people um because they totally
deserve to be um so there is a
really so my co-founder joel um and we
we've been co-founders for a couple of
businesses now so we worked in tech
together et cetera got very different
mindsets with these things as well but
he was also a supplement skeptic and he
had really bad gut problems right so he
actually ended up curing his gut
problems by taking sim proof which was
the first time that he was like well the
supplement can work how interesting and
actually if you go into the basics of
course supplements work like ultimately
you know there are so many narratives
that are counter-intuitive right but
there are narratives where we understand
they work if you're pregnant you're told
to take supplements if you've got a
young baby they're i've just had a baby
as you know like they were immediately
injecting with vitamin k vitamin d that
is the when i say immediately i mean in
the first 10 minutes of her life right
so you know
there are multiple examples where
science um and like and medicine know
that that's evidence-based and worth
doing we're told in the uk to take
vitamin d all winter now with covid
vitamin d is one of the most popular
supplements etc etc right there are
multiple narratives where we know that
supplements work yet
the reason these narratives and that
they take big headlines like supplements
don't work don't waste don't waste your
money don't waste your time kind of
thing the reason they take hold is
actually
totally deserved and it's the marketing
industry that's behind supplements
that's the reason so the main challenge
here is price most supplements you buy
for 10 pounds um for example in a high
street shop like a boots or holland and
barrett
has
absolutely nothing in it and they are
legally obliged to tell you this and
this was sort of the journey that i went
on like starting to understand the
industry that i'd be going into right so
um give you a bit of backstory on this
as when i started to go to um uh planet
organic or whole foods right i was a bit
you know i just asked more questions
about all this stuff like why i don't
get that um
long story short
all the supplements in there cost 30 40
pounds a pot but if you buy exactly the
same thing on the high street boots
holland and barrett they cost 10 pounds
with a one penny deal and you're like
that makes no sense like i walked five
minutes away and like there was so much
more anyway the main reason is there is
a discrepancy
in the industry that is global
where you can basically put a minimum
amount of nutrients in and make a
marketing claim and you make that same
marketing claim
um whether you put in the minimum amount
or the right amount according to science
so give you an example that i use
regularly because they're such a big
company it's hardly offensive to anyone
omega-3s
right everyone grows up in their parents
i was taking omega-3 when i was like 11
to 18. yeah right and your parents want
you to take omega-3s um there's loads of
evidence around omega-3s and whether you
take fish oil or your plant-based and
you say algae oil and by the way fun fun
um you know uh meandering facts um fish
that are where most people get their
omega-3s from um fish don't naturally
make their own omega-3 they get it from
algae so it's really interesting but
like you know this idea that we only can
get omega-3s from fish no fish can only
get it from algae that's their main food
source they get it from algae then we
eat fish so if you get it from algae
you're getting a more sustainable
natural source it's where it actually
comes from which is a fun fact anyway so
the the the reality
is amiga 3 so 7cs being the biggest
brand in the world was the one that i
used when i first started looking into
this like what a scam this all is um if
you buy their number one bestseller
which is the number one best-selling
omega-3 oil in the world which is 15
pounds a month um you get
45 milligrams of omega-3 in each daily
dose
fine
that is the minimum amount you are
allowed to put in globally to make a
marketing claim like promotes a healthy
heart function promotes a healthy
brain function etc
the right amount according to science is
a minimum of 250.
so that is all the science research any
paper will say it's a minimum of 250.
so
if you work that out
you need to take
a daily dose of seven c's for six days
straight to get one day's worth of what
science is telling you but they're a
marketing company so they do what they
want so they put in the minimum amount
and so what happens this sort of
perpetuates what happens is the global
prices of supplements are cheap because
everyone is putting in the minimum
amount to make a marketing claim and the
maximum amount or at least the minimum
you need according to science is so far
off the actual dose that when a regular
consumer like you or me will go into a
shop and say this one's 30 pounds this
one's five pounds i'm just gonna pick
the five pound one you're getting the
same thing five times six is thirty um
it's just that you would have to take
seven c six days in a row so then what
happens sadly
is people feel nothing from the impact
because they're having way less from the
scientific dose that you actually need
for health and well-being and so people
like basically start taking supplements
feel nothing from it not getting any
benefits yeah i think they're rubbish
and that that is across the whole
industry so like 99 of supplements
that you buy
um basically
use the marketing amount not the
scientific amount and they're legally
required to put all of this on the pack
so this isn't just
some guy with an agenda trying to sell
his product i'm telling you that you can
do all this research yourself but the
problem is is it in an asterisk
it's on the back you have to be a savvy
consumer i've had this conversation so
many times with people where they then
got into their own supplement covers and
it's the box they usually throw away as
well right so you throw away that box
and suddenly you don't even have the
thing on there so you're like well i'm
not really sure but next time you go and
look you will see the difference between
the rda and the site also the marketing
amount the scientific amount and it's
usually
miles apart so
the industry is set up to scan people
one way or another everyone is in
collusion there are so many
bad things that go into these products
so up until recently um
well i think they still do it but i'd
like to say up until recently
phytobiotics we're using a product
called
titanium dioxide which is basically like
a poison um in their products so you
know that is like a it's literally on a
banned list now um so having like recall
products
but the reason people do this is because
they use fillers so
okay so if you think about the size of a
pill right so think about a multivitamin
in general you put a bunch of different
things in um a lot of these compounds
are tiny right like a speck like a speck
of dust would be like the amount you
need per day and if you put all of that
together you get to a capsule
and then to pack it together and not
look like you're underselling a customer
you pack the rest with chalk or with
bulking agents or whatever it is so that
you get to like a full-size product so
what we do at heights for example is two
clever things one we use these bespoke
capsules where it's omega-3 on the
outside and then the capsule is injected
on the inside so each one is two pills a
day so you as a customer taking two
pills a day but you're really getting
four if that makes sense okay because as
you can see it's like two in one every
single capsule okay um and then secondly
there's no synthetic
caking agents or bulking powders
whatsoever because whilst we're creating
the product my business partner and i
were like if that's how everyone this is
one of the cool things about coming
total outsiders the industries you are
stupid questions right it's total first
principle thinking but not because we're
geniuses because we don't know how to
make the product so if you don't know
how to make the product you come at it
like well why wouldn't you fill an
entire product up with ingredients but
the reason is because no one else does
that but having no training in this
space having never worked in it you
don't ask those questions you go well
that's what we want to do we want to
fill it with ingredients okay so that's
why
supplement equals scam because the whole
the whole industry is set up to
basically scam consumers because the
marketing claim is so radically
different to the scientific claim
and i guess what you guys are trying to
do is approach supplements with a more
evidence-based kind of
less scammy perspective simple it's like
this is what the science says
this is what the science says about the
nutrient requirement to get this level
of impact on a daily basis that's why we
chose it that's why it's in the product
this is why it's good for you it's as
simple as that i mean it is honestly
like what you would hope to expect from
any modern day company it's like clear
communication this is what you the
consumer are hoping to get yes this is
what we're selling you
it's really that simple the contract
but um
it's so murky and i have no idea why but
supplement companies have this enormous
loophole and um and this is the weird
thing it's like a global loophole
they're just like they all do it that's
very strange yeah um i'm gonna ask you
more more about her heights in a minute
but um i wanted to ask you about uh your
recent baby so yes firstly congrats on
that front thank you uh how how old is
she now two weeks and one day two weeks
in one day yeah my name is margo is that
right argo correct and there's some very
cute pictures on your instagram thank
you we're gonna take a very quick break
to introduce our sponsor for this
episode and that is brilliant i've been
using brilliant for the last two plus
years they're a fantastic platform for
learning maths science and computer
science with engaging and interactive
online courses and the great thing about
brilliant is that they really teach
stuff from a very first principles based
approach it's almost like the way that
we were taught in places like oxford and
cambridge where you learn a concept and
then you apply the concept to an
interesting problem rather than just
being spoon-fed stuff like we initially
learned in school my favorite courses on
brilliant are the computer science ones
as some of you guys might know i was
torn between applying to medicine and
computer science i went for medicine in
the end but i always had an affinity to
computer science and taking the courses
on brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
what's it like becoming a father
changing gears completely yeah okay so
uh initially i would say i mean there's
two things to say here one is that uh
you know
there is a great sense of uselessness so
all of my friends who are um dads were
all like oh god it's amazing and you
know get ready for all of this stuff
right but actually the reality if i'm
being totally honest and i like to be as
honest as i possibly can be with people
um the dependency on the mum
is a thousand-fold the dependency on the
dad okay so
it's a really interesting time because
you're um you want to help i i want to
help my wife as much as i possibly can
but practically speaking uh the baby is
totally reliant on her for breastfeeding
right and i can't help with that um and
we were lucky because you know somebody
would struggle with breastfeeding and
ours has started off really well so we
haven't moved her onto a bottle yet and
that's choice of my wife so basically
you know mum is in the driving seat dad
is there to support so my job is change
nappies um you know soothe her when i
can but actually you know from a very
practical point of view it is
eye-opening um to think of yourself
suddenly right as a kid and just how
much your mum had to do for you compared
to your dad i'm sure it all changes and
i'm sure i will become more helpful and
more more useful as she matures but it's
so fascinating right now just to see the
redundant role of a father in the early
days right i mean honestly you could not
be there and i don't think i don't think
evolution would have any difference it
would make no difference okay so that's
like one side of it which is the sort of
uh self
how we describe it like i'm not being
useful enough kind of vibe you said
there was there was a second yeah
i guess the second is like two-sided as
well one is that um you know when she
was born everyone told me about that you
know how i'd have this philosophical
moment of of sheer fascination and
bewilderment etc the thing is i am a
very spiritual person so i i've been on
a big spiritual journey for the last 10
years um constantly working on trying to
be more in tune yeah with my
spirituality one way or another in
whatever way you might define it i'm
happy to talk about it but the point
being because of that setup in my head i
was like really ready for this moment
right this existential moment um and
maybe it's because i have already
experienced existential moments in my
life um and thought deeply about them
and i spent time reading around them and
self-inquiry and all that stuff but i
didn't have that moment they handed me
my baby
and like honestly it could have been
anyone's baby yeah and i wasn't like oh
my god i'm cooing after this thing i
can't believe it i was like oh [ __ ] this
is my responsibility what am i going to
do with that um and you know the fact
that you're in the room
with them means you know it's your baby
yeah but otherwise you know who's to say
it is it's just a really weird you know
it doesn't come out of you the man so on
that basis like they hand you this thing
and you're like okay well i'll deal with
it okay so that was like weird right
because i think i felt like disappointed
in myself i'm not having the spiritual
enlightening like moment of oh my god
clarity hundred percent and then you
know they had these like really doubting
questions you know do i love her do i
care for her i thought these things
would be natural to me but actually i'm
learning that they develop over time um
time spent like any relationship um so
that's one side the other side is that
two nights ago she just stopped
breathing um yeah so sunday night right
um 10 p.m
first lesson of fatherhood was uh don't
try and get an early night made the
mistake of trying to get an early night
um paternity was like first part of
percentage anyway it was over so back to
work and on monday um and she just
stopped breathing she like starts to
like really struggle to breathe starts
making these weird sounds starts to go
pink then blue i'm on the phone at 999
my wife is like inconsolably crying
we're doing like i'm watching some john
ambulance like how to resuscitate a baby
not really the kind of video you're
hoping to search for in the first two
weeks
super helpful nhs 999 person like
calming me down telling me what to do
etc was really really great ambulance
came
um she ended up
just getting back into breathing like
sort of naturally then massive cries and
all this stuff and yeah like nhs just
tell us that this is extremely common
one of the most common ambulance call
outs is for babies that won't breathe
that they need to resuscitate and i was
like what they're like yeah they don't
talk about this but yes it's a really
common thing and sometimes that's how
babies die they just forget to breathe
because they're so new at breathing they
just forget you're like
what on earth so
the other side of this is like you know
i've had my first fatherly panic which
is like oh my god i can't even look
after a child and like oh god i'm so
sorry that didn't say i loved you so
much like immediately so you have that
sort of moment where you know you
realize you do inherently deeply care
about this thing um because suddenly
these emotions like all come out of you
that you like the fear and
responsibility that you didn't really
know were in you if that makes sense so
it wasn't the kind of thing i was hoping
to experience by now already um but
crazy no had like randomly stopped
breathing yeah and i was just happy
you guys noticed that she'd randomly
stop reading because i mean my wife is
super astute um because yeah it's not
easy she she was um
basically making these weird sounds
looked like she was struggling it was
just after feeding we were sitting her
up right um it looked like she was
struggling a little bit and we're like
patting her back and stuff and but her
eyes were streaming and she wasn't
crying we were trying to make her cry by
like moving her legs moving her arms
trying to annoy her because you can't
cry
if you're choking oh yeah and you can't
breathe so you know baby crying is like
great sign
um
but it was like five minutes of this
like really struggling to breathe um
going bluer and bluer us freaking out
and then like you know it's weird
because in some senses i think it's
almost worse that they're like yeah
she's totally normal she's perfectly
healthy don't worry about it and you're
like don't worry about it right much
rather you told me she had a breathing
problem or something but this might
happen again they're like well you know
it could it's not as likely once it's
happened once
but could um yeah we get this all the
time
isn't that bad
so now your listeners know that that is
a thing to look out for what was going
through your mind as she was slowly
getting pink and blue well the thing is
i am a very
my
um i
growing up my dad was ill a lot okay so
i'm highly desensitized to health
concerns from people
um i've been in the hospital a lot um i
have
i guess at the point i'm trying to
maintain i'm very cool calm and
collected in the moment um all of these
things are great they have their
downsides i can be highly apathetic in
situations i should be more emotional
um you know where people are really
looking to me to have a distressed
emotion i can seem like i'm emotionless
and i'm not a very emotional person but
my reaction in a moment of high stress
and great challenge especially
health-wise
is to be super calm and practical which
quite useful in this moment so straight
on the phone to 909 having a calm
conversation describing things a bit
like a robot right so it's only after
the fact
that i sort of am able to like
access my emotions if that makes sense
okay
this point that you say about about
about apathy i think this is something
that i i have an issue with in that um
often
like i will feel stuff but it would not
be
it would not be like uh broadcast on my
face and so often you know my husband
would ask me like how are you feeling
and i'm like oh you know feeling pretty
good and she'd be like why don't you
tell your face
apparently like i just have a resting
kind of apathy yeah resting calm face
resting board face is kind of like
rusty calm face is probably a better one
yeah even especially when doing these
sorts of interviews where i have to
really try and
because i'm i'm fully engaged but but
the way i look it's like you know either
droopy is like really bored and people
are like yeah so
um yeah
how did you realize that this was
something that that you had kind of this
this mismatch between like the emotions
on the inside and like the outward
expression of those emotions well my mum
told me okay that's always always a good
way to get uh to get started but you
know my mom is
at the opposite so my look my my dad was
very stoic my dad had like i said a lot
of things like it's a long list of
things that he had wrong with him he was
blind he had heart attacks he had gout
he had diabetes
he had like you know slip discs and like
just everything on the list that a human
body can go through over multiple times
pneumonia so many times bypasses like
you name it um and was always really
stoic and really calm in the moment um
my mom would like freak out in the
moment understandably right like really
panic really freaking out and if you're
a young kid and this is happening
regularly um you sort of learn to
desensitize yourself a little bit
because the freaking out doesn't help a
solution it doesn't get you any closer
to anything um i guess in my experience
until my father passed away like up
until that moment he'd always survived
and come back so you also have the
experience that you know the fear and
and in the moment the the
you know the panic in the moment not
only doesn't
um help you solve it but it also isn't
representative of the outcome
if that makes sense yeah the like if
it's the first time you've seen someone
struggle for their life
the fear that you feel is is the same
fear of essentially assuming that
they're dead right it's that like total
panic that things are over
and i think the reality is like because
i'd so many times gone through the cycle
of well he's really sick we need to go
into hospital we need to get him support
but he'll be get better
really helps temper your emotions so i
think i have this sort of
natural disposition i'm very glass half
full guy anyway but i always have a
natural disposition that everything will
be okay
and i think that really does help in the
moment to like get in touch with how to
solve a thing
does this apathy have any downsides
um yeah which is that essentially people
think that i
don't care
and it's really funny because you know
feedback from my team for example we do
really open 365 all the time like care
without compromise is a heights value so
we have four values and one of them is
care without compromise which means that
like we'll go to the nth degree for
customers if you're not happy we'll i
mean we'll do silly things or spend tons
of money on making sure that without
compromise and also the other thing
coming back to without compromising is
because we think you know in the special
supplement space there's so much
compromise so we choose the highest
quality ingredient our most bioavailable
source most sustainable everything is
like you know what would like how would
ferrari source this is like without
compromise every different level anyway
so
the flip side on this is people tell me
that i'm very caring very emotional but
in the moment of a challenge i think it
can be really surprising to people
because i am an emotive person i'm
expressive you know um
i am an ambivert but you know everyone
that meets me thinks i'm an extrovert
anyway so all of these things is not
what you expect as a reaction from
someone in the moment when suddenly i
sort of go into myself and i'm like how
do we how do we calm down and solve this
everyone be calm and then and that takes
it's less about like how i feel about
that but it's more that i am aware that
it really
surprises other people not necessarily
in a good way yeah i guess it's it's one
of those things where
um
malcolm gladwell talks about this in his
book talking to strangers yeah um where
you know there are there are some people
who have an emotional response which is
broadcast on their face and some people
who have an emotional response which is
not broadcast on their face and how this
can cause a lot of problems um and and
the examples that he uses which are
always the most like um you know
interesting ones where uh you know a
murder trial where the way the housemate
responded uh was not how people thought
the housemate should have responded and
she should have been more distraught and
crying openly but instead she kind of
retreated into herself and that made
people think she was cold and
emotionless therefore she must have been
the murderer and ended up getting like
wrongly imprisoned for
some some number of years because of
this phenomenon whereby you know we
think that people should be displaying
the things that they're feeling on the
inside more so on the outside um
and so i like when i when i read that a
year or two ago it it really resonated
with me because i felt that i probably
have that issue where i'll often ring my
mum and she'd be like why do you look so
sad mm-hmm
like she's like genuinely been a great
day like what the hell do i like yeah
yeah that kind of thing but how does
that make you feel
it makes me feel like oh that's a good
question um it makes me feel like
sometimes like oh maybe i am sad i'm
just like convincing myself i'm not sad
um and that like people talk about how
70 of communication is body language and
how body language is all like
subconscious and maybe i am like
subconsciously feeling sad but i'm just
actually telling myself i'm happy
because i've drunk the stoicism kool-aid
for too long
um
and it's only kind of kind of speaking
to other people who also have this that
they're like actually it's it's kind of
okay that your face does not reflect how
you're feeling inside like you can't
accept that part of yourself and not
feel like it's something you have to
change but i feel like it's probably
quite quite useful when it comes to
being an entrepreneur um and you
mentioned entrepreneurship is
uh kind of a journey of of anxiety i
want you to talk a little bit more about
that because you've been a serial
entrepreneur for a long time
what do you mean about this like an
anxiety component yeah so um i mean
there's a great quote i mean it's by lao
tzu but i'm gonna completely [ __ ] it up
on that basis which is you know
something along the lines of or the
paraphrasing of it is um depression is a
sadness on reflection of your past and
anxiety is a sadness for the outcomes of
your future which is why presence is the
only cure right you stay in the moment
and then you're not really accessing the
sadness of the past and what you would
change or the future scenarios of the
anxiety that you can't control
um and i think a much better quote that
i can remember because i can quote
pretty much anything from him which is
eckhart tolle who i told you about last
week when we were chatting down under
the audiobook oh man you're in for a
treat but so he he says his brilliant
thing which is um stress and anxiety
is a symptom of being here
but wanting to be there being here but
wanting to be there oh interesting it's
so simple yeah it says everything he
says this is why it's so good you know
and he said like you you can't ever be
there
so
pure facts that's why i think his
spiritual work is
so poignant because he speaks and just
like talks to you like an adult and it's
very he's very binary so you either read
his stuff and you're like this is
garbage or you read it and it all makes
sense and that totally depends where you
personally are in a spiritual journey at
that point no judgement because you can
come back to it it means something to
you differently a different time
but you know literally it's like you
can't ever be there
the only place you can be is here and
now
so creating a mental image the way you'd
like to be
in the future fine do that if you want
your body's here now so you're not there
and that disassociation with like this
battle with like no no but i want to be
there you know it's like doesn't matter
it's not reality so it's really nice
like distinction of like fact and
fiction and your mind is always playing
in fiction but your body is always in
reality right you're not literally time
traveling you're not literally in the
future you're not five minutes in the
future you're not three months in the
future you're literally here and so the
constant like battle there is some of
this understanding that can manifest
into some anxiety now
when you think about it from um
um
you know i'm gonna literally rip off one
of my own tweets because just like you
know i had this realization and it was
quite popular and it sort of made made
its own version of sense which is um you
know whether you call it manifestation
or you call it um a business plan right
one way or another you are trying to
predict the future and like different
people will call it different things a
neuroscientist will call it um you know
neuroplasticity yeah right you call it
the brain's ability to change the
brain's ability to think about you know
how to mold itself into the future that
it wants to be tomorrow um but a
business exec you know at a business
school is going to say create a business
plan and think about where you want to
be in three months three years etc and
and create that um you know a spiritual
person we'll call it manifestation and
i'm going to sit here and i'm going to
imagine the world that i want to live in
and then i'm going to write the steps
back from it and i'm going to create a
bit of a plan and a path they're all the
same thing one way or another they're
all the same thing and they all sort of
exist in this world of um disassociating
to an extent where you are today with
where you want to be and there's always
going to be that kind of tension so if
you're an entrepreneur your job is
literally always to be spending time
like who do i need to hire yeah what do
we need to do why do we need to do it
how am i going to get there what money
do i need these are all questions you
can't necessarily answer and so you're
constantly like searching in the dark or
looking at youtube videos or asking
friends like how to unlock these things
for yourself but ultimately they're all
questions that need to be answered
for the future you
um
there is you know an aspect where
i think time management is so important
here like
if you overload yourself with spending
all your time in that future reality and
don't spend enough of your time as an
entrepreneur sort of working in the here
and now what you can affect today that's
when things can get a bit out of hand in
my experience
um you know and it's just again the
disassociation with presence and future
concepts two thoughts uh number one is
around goal setting
uh everyone talks about how goal setting
is like so important etc etc and the
importance of a business plan and a
vision and manifestation and all that
kind of stuff uh i've always been
historically like anti-goal-setting
because it's always it's never quite sat
right with me that why am i kind of
deferring my happiness for a future date
when i achieve a certain type of goal
um compared to you know just focusing on
enjoying the journey and like enjoying
each day on his own merit but there is
like a balance there between like you
know it's it's not a case of live every
day as if it was as if it was your last
because that would end up you know i'd
end up being like a heroin addict well
exactly um
but it's like how how how do you
manage that balance between yes you want
to grow and you want heights to go big
and you want to impact which is all
futurey type stuff and also you want to
kind of be present and that that sort of
thing
yeah i think it's a great question i
think this is where
um and you know cringy but i think this
is sometimes where
purpose um
and working and defining on purpose your
company's purpose your purpose which can
change by the way um but i think this is
where the stuff plays in really nicely
because i don't necessarily think about
stuff in terms of goals goals i don't
know goals always feels a little bit um
it's not necessarily true but it feels a
bit uh mercenary or financially led or
you know there's always a reason why you
need that goal um whereas purpose to me
is a bit more like a direction of the
person that i'm i'm i'd like to become
that i'm on the way to being that every
day that i am working towards living my
purpose
is a step in the right direction and
i'll make mistakes and i'll forget to
live it entirely one day or whatever but
it helps me knowing that i'm going in
the right direction and because i'm a
bit of a hippie i believe that
by going in that direction for long
enough for consistently enough and the
most important thing here by the way is
like enjoying doing that yeah so if you
have a sense of where you're going if
you have an idea of what your purpose is
and again doesn't need to be some big
grand statement if you have a sense of
your own personal values and you ask
yourself you know what are those values
that i'm living every single day and am
i living up to them
those things will just basically ensure
that you are spending more time
happy
because you're spending more time doing
the things that you know are serving you
well serving you and serving others and
the
the compound effect of that as you're
more likely to be getting to whatever
this sort of magical goal is like being
honest i don't have a set goal i don't
have a like i want to be you know i know
we both um know and are friends with
stephen bartlett right and he's very
specific you know i have i want to be
running this nine-figure business in
this many years and blah blah blah and
i'm like that's fine like for you for me
i have very different sort of outlook on
that stuff which is um i've identified
my um like five key guiding values right
and you know they include
fluffy words like contribution and
impact yeah right but like you know how
can you
spirituality is at the base of these
things because i think like spirituality
is a great base to layer things um
well basically is a great base mental
well-being goes above that
integrity contribution and
i mean like ultimately impact is the the
for me
the key of where i want to see my life's
work go you can't have impact broadly um
if you're just impacting one person like
you can but if you are
an entrepreneur like me and you you do
think big and you think about scale and
that's just inherently how i think um
i know by putting at the top of my
pyramid of values if you will i want to
have impact inherently i have to think
big apparently i have to think about how
am i going to have an impact on more
people because i happen to care about
emotion i care about i've had a personal
experience with mental well-being um it
is
bonkers to me that nutrition can play
such an enormous impact and that we can
create products high quality products a
great brand like which plays into my
creativity and the things i'm good at um
you know the fact that we can build a
great brand that can have that kind of
impact that stuff all serves me well but
there's other stuff that i can do with
impact as well and i might not be doing
that today but if as long as i'm sort of
leading up towards where that might go
in 10 20 years i like that i don't have
a clear idea of who i am in 20 years
only that it will be leading to impact
because i will be contributing does that
sort of make sense yes i think a very
succinct way of saying this because
people talk a lot about passion as well
is um
i think and i have thoughts a lot about
this but i think that your passion is
something that you do for you right
you've got guitar over there maybe
that's a passion of yours so your
passion is for you your purpose is for
others
so as long as you're thinking about
where your purpose is going and i mean
you've got a great example right you're
an educator online to millions of people
that's purpose there's other people but
guitar
for all i know you're [ __ ] but you have
fun that's great yeah there you go
passion
okay i have so many questions uh i'm i'm
going to kind of just give you the
questions that i've got floating in my
head and then we can start with one of
them but you'll have an idea of like
where i'm going with this so maybe
that'll that'll guide the answers yeah
so you mentioned spirituality a lot yeah
i want to know like what is spirituality
like what does it mean to you and like
how did you discover spirituality
because i feel like this is an area in
which i want to discover spirituality i
always feel i have to i know
with all the spirituality type of stuff
um
so there's that side of things you
talked about um your five guiding values
and so i also wanted to ask like how did
you figure out what your values are and
you also have this like presumably some
sort of guiding mission guiding purpose
and i want to find out like how you
figured out that side of things
so
should we start with the spirit
spirituality thing like what the hell is
spirituality yes how did you get in how
does someone like me get into
spirituality yeah so yeah i don't
actually have a good defining there's a
great i love questions like this because
it you know makes you sort of realize as
well you know it'd be nice to sort of
solidify the thinking down into
something succinct not my strong suit
but you know i guess in the summary um
for me spirituality is a connection to
all things knowing that um you know my
second favorite youtube channel after
you obviously yeah
i probably said it badly but oh my god
right
that channel um does such an amazing job
of uh in my opinion anyway especially
the spaces like you know very sciencey
ones so such a great job of sort of
explaining just how much of a speck of
dust in the universe we are
um that can be either the most
depressing realization of your life or
the most enlightening one because um
once you realize that you are
so insignificant
that you're like
in the grand scheme of things that you
know everything in a sense has to be
connected it really helps you um connect
to nature for example so one of the
things that
is definitely the most hippie things
about me is i could literally sit and
stare at a tree in like total wonder um
like it's the first time i've ever seen
a tree right because um when i look at
that tree i just sit there and like
marvel at the concept of the fact that
this thing is basically how i'm
breathing right i am so connected to
that tree
maybe not that specific one but in the
grand scheme of things if you've ever
watched any planet earth or any david
attenborough documentary or just any
great documentaries on how the planet
exists and works you realize one
absolute wonder that all of these forces
that are conspiring against each other
actually conspire together
to create the first you know life on
earth that then evolved into man and all
of this stuff you know that that sort of
um total very high level bird's eye view
like bewilderment okay how we're here
having this conversation is in a sense
you know how i think about spirituality
what i
don't do and i think this is where i had
a very so until i was 24 like hey i
hated the word spirituality i think it's
cringe and i hate it so much that's why
i i'm comfortable using it now because
it's like the antithesis of who i was
which is another thing identity is very
interesting conversation to have like
separately as well but
um
you know the identity of who i was as
someone who grew up jewish um my parents
jewish not religious but my you know
we'd have to go to synagogue on you know
the religious holidays and all this
stuff and it's in hebrew and i don't
speak hebrew i'm in england so you know
and judaism is a weird one as well
because it's a race and a religion which
is the benefit that you get both the
racists and people that don't like your
religion all at the same time so
it's like it is a weird one to grow up
in but culturally it's very connected
right so the benefits of it is there's
really nice culture so i always used to
say like i really like the culture but
like this religion stuff is bollocks to
me i don't believe in god um i don't
believe in being force-fed anything um i
you know in my opinion
i'm sure it's extremely offensive to
most people listening and of any
religion but you know
growing up religious like in a way is
indoctrinating your children with a sent
with a belief right you don't do that
necessarily you don't do that
consciously on purpose as a good parent
you try and like let your kid work out
what they need to work out in the world
but
when your religion
is um you're like a huge part of your
identity
and it's a big part of your family and
when it's a big part of your like
traditions and your culture and all of
this stuff and
when it is most important when it's your
only sense of connection to spirituality
that's when it all gets very complicated
so for me where i challenged this
concept was i don't believe in god
right big capital g word like big white
beard or whatever it is i'm being told
is this person in the sky yeah
so
i'm not religious
because i don't like judaism any more
than i like christianity islam or
anything i'm just like it's not my
religion or their religion it's like i
don't like any of the religions but i
love the teachings okay so i love i love
the point of religion right the point of
religion is when you break it down is to
teach people good values that's that's
ultimately what it's all about every
single story in the bible whichever
bible you read is all about really
trying to teach you how to be good not
bad and then people obviously hijack
these stories or whatever but like
fundamentally that's the point of
religion
is through the years
culture-wise when there wasn't tv and
there weren't stories and everything
else there were books and stories and
you'd pass these down so people learn
how to treat each other well wicked i
buy into that that's amazing now it's
all like politicized which is like the
church owns so like so much real estate
and blah blah blah it's all about money
and you know that really starts to make
me feel very disconnected from spiritual
lessons so growing up i felt really
disconnected to this idea of religion
and my dad was basically the only person
in my family who was like you know quite
into religion because he had faith and
hope um because he was very ill and sick
so i think that's another thing people
have that sort of come to jesus come to
god moment when they're sick and he was
a lot um so when he passed away i sort
of threw out all my religious beliefs
and everything and i went quite nihilist
so it was very much like there's nothing
afterwards you just live you die
went into a bit of a depression but
that's quite normal i think if you have
a close parent who passes away
um and i was just totally anti the whole
thing um
probably rudely so which is like now
someone tells me that they're religious
i'd love to have a conversation with
them because actually usually the way
that i think about spirituality is
exactly how they speak about religion so
we have a good conversation because
we're actually on the same page it's
just that i don't label mine with like
i'm not a thing i just believe in the
same things you do which is that there's
more than this and that's actually
enough and if you take away a lot of the
labels you're all speaking about the
same thing i
very randomly was at a dinner
and some guy was there talking about
this thing called ayahuasca
i've never heard of it couldn't
pronounce it didn't know what he was
talking about
but i was in this like really bad place
and i'd been like really depressed for
six months um maybe maybe the best part
of a year to be honest um my friend was
like let's go and do it and i was like
sure nothing better to do
but it's interesting because i didn't
know i think you know this is like 10
years ago now right like people have
much more awareness around something
like ayahuasca and psychedelics in
general now um ten years ago less so so
i didn't know at all what i was getting
myself into and i sort of turned even
though like you say ayahuasca it's yeah
it's not only really the tech pros
yeah so like what what what does it look
like to just go and take ayahuasca yes
so um ayahuasca is
essentially it's a plant
um so it's tree sap ultimately and it's
a special vine that grows in um south
america so it grows in peru grows in
hawaii
there's indian versions of it as well so
it's got sort of different names in
different countries but it's this
very ancient used by shamans deep in the
jungle
um
and and it's it's very it's the most
potent psychedelic in the world
so
it is
not something that you do recreationally
um there's no dipping your toe so to
speak you're either in or you're out and
uh you know it's a six to eight hour
experience minimum
um so for all of those reasons you know
it's uh
it's not something that you choose to do
lightly you've got to do it in the right
company all of these things you can't
basically i mean i've heard loads of
stories about people when new there was
a
craze in new york with people just doing
it in their apartments and stuff but
like really you want to be doing it with
people that you trust in a safe
environment with people who know what
they're doing
and
um my experience of it and it basically
says green liquid you drink it it's like
you drink a shot okay that's that's the
actual thing you drink a shot of this
right liquid it has a
um and this is where it all gets
mystical and amazing it has this
compound in it called um
dmt
and dmt is nicknamed the god particle
and actually the the thing that like dmt
is the only uh particle that is in
absolutely every living thing full stop
so it is the that's why it's called the
god particle because it just happens to
appear in everything whether it's a leaf
or a human brain
and actually
very weirdly the way that the human
brain is set up
is
we have it's very weird but we're
basically we're we've got tons of dmt
inside us already we've got dmt and
we've got dmt inhibitors and very
weirdly what's going on inside our
brains when we're awake and conscious
is our dmt inhibitors are stopping the
dmt from flooding our system and when
the dmt floods our system that's when we
get dreams so when we fall asleep
we get into a really relaxed state and a
deep sleep and the dmt inhibitors start
to like relax or whatever our brains get
flushed with this dmt so you ever woken
up with a dream and been like
i
i've never met those people in my life
i've never seen that monster or this
experience or those colors i don't know
where any of that came from and it feels
it's the first it's for the most
tangible way that you could explain to
anyone who doesn't believe in the
afterlife or anything else it's like but
then explain that you never met those tv
you'd have no idea what these things are
even if you've never seen like a tv show
before you'd have those kind of dreams
right and that's like a bit weird and
wacky happens to you first when you're
young if you've dreamt you know or had
any of these wacky dreams you're just
like i can't explain that stuff right so
that's kind of the crazy thing about dmt
which is that we already have it in us
yeah and when you drink ayahuasca what
you're actually drinking what they
prepare for you is dmt and the inhibitor
together okay so then you flush your
system with more dmt and the naturally
occurring dmt that's already in your
brain and suddenly you're under the
spell and obviously everyone's
experience is very different but my
first experience they they say they say
with ayahuasca the point is that you go
in with an intention that doesn't mean
anything to me right for the layman like
that just sounds like more wacky words
and when you're a cynic like i was um
you know that's an incredibly triggering
way to speak to me as well i'm like
going with an intention yeah like my
intention what is it obvious yeah yeah
um
but i went in with this intention of
like i i want to stop being depressed i
want to stop what i feel now was
basically it
um you know i won't go into like you
know the whole thing because uh there's
a great author called michael pollan who
wrote this fantastic book called how to
change your mind which is the journey of
psychedelics he's an amazing author um
and it's really fun and he says you know
describing your psychedelic experiences
is ineffable so it's an absolute waste
of time however
um they said that on the tim ferriss
podcast i thought it was quite fun but
you know my experience was to understand
i sort of came out of my body and i saw
nature and as
horribly
crass and cringe as it sounds
i for the first time sort of had this
experience of seeing birds bees trees
oceans rivers all of these things
interconnecting on like a big global
scale together and sort of understanding
and seeing that um
these structures
predate human existence and have
inherent wisdom in them to have this
like natural occurring coexistent
experience
to such a deep level that i started to
see reincarnation
um on i guess some quite scientific i
started to see it on a way that i could
understand so this concept of
reincarnation aka um you know previous
thinking was you from me you live you
die that's it my dad had just died
that's it that's why i was depressed
there's no more there's nothing else
this was like um actually um
you know
when your
pet dies and you bury it turns into
ashes it feeds the trees the trees grow
right when um you know when it rains it
goes into a river that river ends up you
know
condensing and becoming a cloud the
cloud rains goes the top of a mountain
becomes a new river you know you sort of
you know these terms from geography but
you actually never give them any thought
when you look at the way that the cycles
of nature work you realize that
everything is a cycle and everything is
reincarnating one way or another and
from one energy form into another and
feeding the next
so we know this stuff to be
scientifically true it's just that we
don't really connect those concepts to
any sort of sense of spirituality and i
was sort of just given this platform to
sort of see this observation to see that
whether i can see it on a daily basis or
not this stuff is happening
every year every 10 years every thousand
years every millennia right it's just
constantly happening all around us and
we're just sort of passing by with our
busy minds not really paying any
attention if you stop and think about it
it's actually very practically happening
around us and that's the way that the
world works in this like unbelievably
unbelievable cycle and then you know you
go even further to think like where even
earth is in the universe right and how
much of a speck that is so
this was kind of the starting point to a
sense of like i say spirituality which
was really um
a sense of connection to other people
and other things um
and you know plants and animals and just
being a total equal i suppose in the
sense of all things on earth yeah and
how did how did this have like lasting
impact beyond the eight hours of the
experience so you know what i um i you
know i had this immense gratitude um
that came to me and i think one of the
really interesting things is you know
i've learned a lot about habit formation
um over the last few years and i think
this is like the first thing that i
learned so you know just for contacts
you do two nights in a row um and i go
back pretty much every year and do
another another session so i've done it
like multiple times now coming up to 20
times every single time is a new sort of
experience new sort of insight depending
on where you are in your journey and
what you want to learn um
the first lesson i learned that was
really interesting is you know had this
wonderful sense of like appreciation and
deep gratitude but like anything having
an insight and having an experience is
not the same as having a daily practice
and so whilst i sort of left and i felt
glowing and you know i was working a
very different startup back then i was i
was running a tech company you know
everyone came in you're like oh my god
you're like glowing you look amazing
where the hell have you been and i was
like yoga retreat um
but i
was like you know
very consciously aware like the first
couple of days i felt incredible and
then suddenly slowly i started to go
back to being myself right you know
someone would say something to me but
snide i'd snap back you know you have
these moments you're a human being and i
think what was really upset me at first
was like god i thought i was you know
going to be this amazing spiritual
person that really understands um all of
these beautiful moments in life and like
be the best person i can be
but actually i'm still me that's really
annoying i can't believe i just i can't
believe i'm so rude to that person just
now like they were just like they might
be having a bad day i'm having a bad day
why am i even having a bad day you know
and actually i learned that
all of these lessons you get they're
like moments in time like reading a
great book right you know we also talked
about this very briefly which is you
know you could read 100 books or you
could read the same book 100 times the
book that you read 100 times is the one
that's going to have the biggest impact
on your life because you'll be putting
it into practice and it's the same thing
with these like ayahuasca retreats or
any sort of spiritual experience which
is
none of it matters unless you commit to
how to put it into your daily life so
this is like the the real hack from my
point of view which is
i don't think you need to go on a
spiritual retreat i don't think you need
to do ios code i think you need to do
any psychedelics you could just um some
people just naturally feel in tune this
way anyway i i've met loads of people
that are as in tune with their sense of
connection to others as i am um and
that's awesome i just needed a spiritual
awakening because i was so far the other
way that's the difference it was like a
complete 180 to me however you might
read a great book and that might speak
to you in that moment um if it creates
an epiphany in your head of like this is
actually the person that i'd like to be
right this is the person i want to
become so these are steps i need to get
there then it all comes down to habits
and it's like a boring thing to say
because habits is such a tried and
tested topic done like you know a
billion times over but
for me this came down to um the first
thing i did for example would say like
listen i want to be a grateful human
being i am so grateful for the
experience i had i'm so grateful that i
now get to experience um the sense of
wonder of connection to things because
that is kind of amazing to find
entertainment in a tree now yeah right
that's i don't i don't need an ipad or a
book or tv i could just go out and be
amazed by a tree that's wicked lucky me
so i want that gratitude to happen on a
on a regular basis so
bearing that in mind um the first thing
i tried to do was um keep a totem by my
bed and by that yeah by that i mean like
i got a stone like literally like a
little crystal stone i put it by my bed
i said that's my gratitude crystal now
um it was just not about me nothing
nothing i literally i literally went
into a shop and i bought a crystal okay
um and it had no significant meaning
necessarily other than i was like when i
look at this crystal it'll be a reminder
that i need to like be thankful so it
could have been like a mug or something
could have been anything okay could have
been anything and actually i then um you
know as as it transpired i don't know
like at some point someone was cleaning
and i lost the crystal or whatever and i
was like god damn it like i'm going to
forget and actually you know i now i
practice gratitude every day i've
actually just made a brain care journal
for heights it's like our next product
which i actually spent like a year of
work on the science of like gratitude
journaling and habit formation um which
we can talk about another time for sure
but i noticed after
say three or four years um so a long
time had passed and i was really good at
gratitude practice but i wasn't waking
up every day
thanking my lucky stars that i woke up
and i was like why not well maybe i was
hungover right maybe i went out last
night and i got wasted and i woken up
and i feel crap today or like i'm sore
or i've got covered or whatever the
thing is i'm not grateful today um i
don't have a natural reminder for it so
i've sort of got out there in a bad mood
and walking around stroppy and it's like
affecting my mood for the day and i'm a
human being
so
i wrote down a note which literally just
said on plain white paper there and then
like i'm grateful i woke up today
and my intention today is and that's all
it says on this piece of paper and i
folded it over and i put it on the side
of my bed and it's literally been there
five years now um and i wake up turn
look at my phone obviously because i'm
human and that's the first thing that i
do even though i want to be this woke
spiritual person but i'm not a human
being and i've got all the same flaws as
everyone else and but this thing is in
the way and the first thing i see is
this no and i'm like oh yeah i'm
grateful for waking up today do you know
it's funny because it's like even though
i've been doing it for years um it still
helps to have the visual prompt and you
know set and setting and all of these
things like when we're trying to learn
good habits you know for studying put
your phone away in another room all of
this stuff compounds right but
having that note there make sure that
the first thing i do every single
morning is remember that i'm a lucky
human being hey i woke up most people
don't like a lot of people don't right
millions of people died today it's just
a fact um so i did wake up one way or
another however i feel that is a fact i
should be grateful for and my intention
is gives me a good moment to just think
before i start looking at my phone or
whatever like
what do i want to do with today and it
can be really simple right it can be
like my intention today is
to be nice to my mum
right or my intention today could be
um to check in on a friend or my
intention today is to be super
productive at work but i just spent like
you know 10 15 seconds i'm not again
pretending that i'm some superhuman it
just gives me 10 to 15 seconds to pause
before i go about my busy day before i'm
like oh my god back to back zoom calls
and all this stuff i've taken that time
for myself just to start and be like
i've centred myself spiritually and this
is like this is a spiritual practice
because
those prompts are about being connected
to something greater than myself do you
have like a sense of
i imagine given that you're human there
are some days where you forget to do
this even even though the things are by
your bedside do you have a sense of like
days in which you don't set an intention
versus days in which you do set an
intention in your kind of n equals one a
b test scenario
what's the difference between those two
days so honestly i don't and the reason
for that is um it is i haven't measured
it right so like you know it's hard for
me to sort of say like well i'm less
productive or i'm less so i'm less than
um but i would say like in general like
as a rule of thumb for me anyway um i
really try to do something every day for
someone else um that's probably the
biggest sense of whether i feel like i
had a fulfilling or productive day one
way or another um and again you know
conversation for another time because
it's a whole other thing but like ego
nothing wrong with ego there's
absolutely nothing wrong with doing
things for yourself it's incredibly
important self-care
right brain care is self-care like you
know genuinely as as it sounds you know
i start the day with heights um first
thing like with a glass of water and the
reason i do those things and there's so
many different like compounding things
but in the first five minutes of my day
i've taken care of my brain giving it
all the nutrients it needs so that i can
thrive today had a big glass of water
hydration is just like nine tenths of
the law anyway if you want to feel good
um
and and i've done a quick gratitude
practice i've already started the day
exceptionally well right that is like a
huge win but those are all things for me
so
thinking a little bit about um you know
how to help impact someone else or how
to do something for someone else
that usually makes me feel emotionally
the best and you can like relate this
stuff quite logically right when you
spend too much time in your mind
thinking about what you need to achieve
what you need to be does this person
like me does that person like me did i
say that thing right that's all me me me
me and the more time you spend thinking
about that stuff the more agitated you
get with yourself anyway so it stands to
reason that doing the opposite taking a
moment to do the opposite think about
someone else actually sort of calms you
down and you know takes you out of
yourself for a moment and that can be
really for me like i still make mistakes
doesn't i still spend plenty of days i'm
sure just thinking of myself but i think
that's usually when i most notice it
it's like [ __ ] i forgot to do anything
for anyone else today and i do feel
quite pent up ah so on on your twitter
you've got you've pinned a thread of
mental health tips and then number four
is no it's not about you obsessing over
me is a root cause to most of our
suffering brackets in my experience i
wonder if you can kind of elaborate on
that a little bit
yeah yeah you're right that is more of
the same right so
i mean one of the
really helpful um aspects of learning
about spirituality is understanding that
um
let's say the opposite right so let's
say you have no spiritual practice um
and
um we're defining spiritual practices in
connection to others yeah i said let's
just say well let's just say that you're
you're not interested in religion you're
not interested in um yeah in in
connection to others necessarily
um um maybe you know speaking very
practical terms you're like a career
obsessive okay right yeah let's just
it's just like a lot of people right
yeah it's all about productivity
climbing that ladder etcetera etcetera
right and you know whatever like you
want a successful life we live in a
material world like
at the end of the day it's not our fault
we're literally like
everywhere plastered around us is
advertising with junk values drink sugar
do this buy more consume that that's
literally the world that we live in by
this jpeg so you know the reality is um
that is the world that we step out into
every day and see
um when you're sort of confronted with
those emotions all the time the
narrative that goes inside your head is
yeah i want that i want that i want that
i want that because um we have an
obsession with wanting and that is a
huge problem as well so you know there's
like a a very simple reality which is
you know if you make a million pounds to
say you want a million pounds if you
want a million pounds then when you get
a million pounds you'll want 10 million
pounds when you get 10 you'll 100 and
the reason is nothing to do with the
quantums of money is because you want
um so the obsession with the wanting is
the root cause of the problem um
actually the joy of like you know having
and the joy of like experiencing what
you already have and appreciating it and
this is where gratitude practice is
genuinely scientifically proven but also
you know spiritually really fulfilling
um is you can enjoy them now and if you
can enjoy what you have today you will
enjoy the million you will enjoy the 10
million and you will enjoy the 100
million they will all mean the same to
you because you'll be enjoying the
moment so
let's say that you have all of these
wanting right the consumerism's around
you you want you want you want and
therefore what's going on inside your
head is how do i get how do i get how do
i get well logically the only way that
you get is by providing some kind of
value to the world so that might be
claiming the ladder in your job that
might be getting you know
notoriety in your field one way or
another but all of these things sort of
lead to
an obsession with your own worth
right and especially your net worth
compared to other people's perception of
you right so other people sort of
validating your amount of net worth and
then hopefully financially rewarding you
as such so that you can get all the
things that you have been trained to
want okay so that sort of um cyclical
reality
is
actually you know sadly what most people
live every day and the reason they live
that is simply because we live in this
like say we live in this sort of society
where um breaking free of the the
question of what do i want
right what do i want therefore how do i
get is a sort of like tyrannical cycle
that just like constantly feeds itself
so the reality is the more you spend
time there it's quite possible that you
will achieve more and then make more
money and then get more and then have
more but the cycle just continues the
numbers zeros go up but the the
experience sort of continues let's flip
that
let's say that you are um
whether it's culturally or naturally
inclined or whatever to just spend time
thinking about other people
right so
you know it's uh
i won't go too weird and wacky you won't
use like dalai lama as an example or
anything like that but you know some of
the happiest people that you meet are
people who work with not much money but
serve other people one way or another
and i think that that's like an
unbelievable insight you know these
people very often um
don't tend to suffer as much from
anxiety they're spending much more time
thinking about how to help other people
being practically useful
the gratitude cycle right so they're
being grateful that they have the
opportunity to serve people the people
that they're serving have the
opportunity to show them gratitude for
what they're doing the cycle is all
about gratitude and being in the moment
serving the person or serving the
community or whatever it is and i think
the trick is like how you find the right
balance because you know i spend a lot
of time thinking about this it's like i
don't want
at the moment i'm not spiritually woke
enough to want to be a monk on you know
the top of a mountain in tibet i want to
provide to society i want to have impact
you know there are many different ways
to do that
however i
i want things too i you know and i don't
i don't shy away from the fact that i
suffer from all of the um
you know imperfections that i say are i
think sorry i think a really good way to
describe this is um
another great way to describe
spirituality is just awareness
okay so you know without sort of tying
myself around and knots on the statement
i have the awareness
that
i
can be self-obsessive i have the
awareness that i can think about myself
too often i have the awareness that i
want to be successful and i want more
money i want to provide for my family i
want my investors to be happy i want my
customers to be happy i want i want
everyone i want so i have the awareness
i want all of these things um but
in the moment that you're stopping
yourself and not just running by the
narrative for the things you want but
stopping yourself and just saying well
hold on a second where's that noise
coming from let's
unpack that for a moment let's spend
some time thinking about why those
things are important
suddenly i'm able to say all right well
i want them so that i can have an impact
at a later date i don't necessarily know
what that means but this is some of the
rationale and reasoning behind it it
doesn't
mitigate the sort of mental health cycle
that goes around here which is like all
the anxiety of the things i could
achieve and what i want but it connects
it to like a higher purpose and for me
like that helps me find some kind of
balance in the middle of the two things
if that makes sense
yes
yeah i definitely find that and i don't
know if you get this like i find that
when i am in my most sort of outcome
goal focused mindset that is when i'm at
least the least happy probably the least
productive too
yeah exactly yeah definitely the least
productive as well yeah actually putting
so much pressure on yourself yeah you
just
but there's the thing
and what's stopping you probably the
internal monologues going on as in the
internal cycle narrative and matter of
your brain
of your mind yeah is usually going into
overdrive in those times because you put
so much pressure on yourself yeah i've
been having this issue a lot recently um
which i've talked about a few times in
videos like you know i'm trying i'm
trying to write a book obviously
obviously i want the book to be
successful i want loads of people to buy
it i wanted to hit the new york times
bestseller list because because then my
personal career as a professional
thought leader goes increased because et
cetera et cetera uh all of these i want
um
and whenever i think about those that
level of i wants
uh it kind of paralyzes me and stops me
from actually writing anything on the
page of course
whereas in the few occasions when i can
probably like
i i i guess be a bit more spiritual
about it like to use that word um and i
think instead
i want to write a book that i'm proud of
basically and i want to have fun doing
it but just a lie once and it's actually
you know i want this book to help at
least one person
and as soon as i start thinking in those
ways suddenly it's like takes the
pressure off it makes it more fun it
makes me it's like a feeling of a breath
of fresh air like oh
i don't have to worry about like all the
external measures of status and prestige
around writing this book
i can actually have fun while doing it
and hope that it helps other people and
there's a line from one of derek
sivers's book uh called anything you
want it's a great book obviously it's
great yeah and i think this is probably
my favorite quote of all time where he
says
never forget why why you're really doing
what you're doing um
are you helping people
are you profitable are you having fun
isn't that enough
and i think you know every time i think
of that i think yeah
that's actually pretty great like you
get to help people get to have fun and
you get to make a profit like some sort
of profit and on top of that like 100
have you ever had a job have you ever
had a job actually first question yes i
worked at the doctor for two years yeah
yeah okay so that was it
yeah sorry i actually knew that i guess
i didn't really mean that kind of job
because i suppose it obviously has a
very fulfilling job doing that yeah
although i've heard obviously you talk
about you but you didn't have that
fulfilling experience quite the level
you wanted that's how you knew that you
weren't yeah yeah i guess so yeah no i
appreciate that actually um i guess the
reason i'm asking is because you know
i've had bad jobs and i've had bad
bosses
and so
it's as simple as that like sometimes i
just remember that which is that i used
to hate work i used to hate work i used
to hate who i work with and i used to
hate my boss
what kind of life is that horrible i
mean that is some people's literal
existence and they managed to find a way
to be happy um i don't have any of that
and like you just said isn't that enough
and sometimes you're like yeah that
really is it's it is you know
fundamentally
um poetic and fulfilling to know that
life can be that simple as well and it's
really like this internal narrative
you know i do think the
massive dichotomy that is confusing and
and and challenging in this whole
scenario is
um i do want
and there is no amount of spiritual
experience i've had book i've read
psychedelic outer body anything insight
that i've ever had that has stopped me
actually wanting
but what that's all given me is balance
to want with a sense of purpose and a
sense of goodness at the heart of it and
a sense of knowing that i want to
contribute back to society in some
meaningful way and that i think is the
balance you know like everything you
know there are the extremes there are
always people who do things extreme
there's always the total malcolm
gladwell outliers who will um do that
one percent of the one percent you know
olympic gold medalists right
phenomenal that's great but like we all
compare ourselves to that person too
often and actually you know that's not
going to create a life of happiness
necessarily for almost everyone on the
earth that won't create a life of
happiness what will is some level of
balance between the things that you want
that are going to make you happy
and the way to sort of find um peace and
harmony within whilst trying to achieve
it yes that's the reality
oh there's a great quote from muhammad
ali which goes along the lines of
um
like
once he won his heavyweight championship
or whatever it's like um i suffered
every day in training for 10 years to
become a champion
and i look at that quote and i feel like
it's it's supposed to be inspiring it's
supposed to be a sort of like you know
hustle and suffer and then that's what
it takes to make it big
and i think of that and i think okay
well if that's what it what it takes i
really don't want to make it big totally
like 10 years of suffering to hold up a
trophy does not seem like anyone's ideas
and you told me about your week earlier
and like what a lovely week
and like you've worked hard to achieve
the bit like the freedom to have that
week
and you will continue to work hard to
have the freedom to achieve that week
but then let's compare you for example
to someone like tony robbins don't i
don't know the guy but you know i don't
imagine that's his week his week will be
like i'm going on tour this day that day
that uh you know he's doing the mohammed
ali type thing yeah he'll go down
again i'm not particular like fanboy of
tony robbins but i respect talented
people putting in the hard hours like we
all do he'll go down probably as the
greatest coach ever right public
speaking whatever you want to call him
like inspirational speaker he'll
probably go down his best ever but like
yeah he does the muhammad ali stuff and
guy has more money than god he could
stop tomorrow but like he gets out of
bed with that sense of drive and purpose
to do that and i
you know i've had plenty of like little
glimpses into that life like raising
money for my comp like my last company
that was a bit of a rocket ship at the
time like you know
getting on a plane every two days and
you know all the stuff that people think
is really glamorous and you did it for
like a couple of weeks and you're like
this isn't the life i thought this was
the life this is not the life um it's
not at all at no time to myself you're
in queues and people emailing all the
time you're like really busy and already
able to connect with people and all of
this stuff and
it only really looks great on the
outside like and the reality i don't
think that's fun at all so you know the
life that you describe
um
is not the kind of life that uh you know
a lot of people even steve who's you
know steve is living more of that life
at the moment right um but you know a
lot of people will assume that the only
way to do this stuff is like with a real
hustle porn gary vaynerchuk kind of
angle and i think that's nonsense i
think what you're saying is
not just healthy
is actually the lifestyle people should
try and aspire to i think there's also
like a level of
like for example if if i describe my
ideal weight where it's like you know i
spend one whole day kind of having kind
of research brainstorms with the team
one whole day filming youtube videos
talking to a camera two afternoons
talking to podcast guests that to me is
like bloody hell that's like really
really fun uh but to a lot of people
that would be like well that's that's
awful i can't imagine wanting to spend a
day a week talking to a camera that
seems like the worst thing ever yeah i
quite enjoy the profession yeah just
just to swap professionally right like a
doctor is not like you know but for a
doctor maybe they're right all day well
this is the thing maybe for not a a
really passionate doctor their ideal
week is five days
helping people but that's great the
point is like identify the thing that
works for you
you know this is the other thing i think
about you know people ask me a lot about
work-life balance yeah i don't think
there is such a thing as work-life
balance at all there's just life and you
should choose to do work that is
fulfilling and meaningful or is giving
you some kind of value like when you're
younger got to work bloody hard to make
it in quite a tough world get a bit of a
name for yourself find the positions you
know i i understand all that right i
think that's really important 20s and
30s absolutely um
you've got to find a way to get yourself
into a recognizable position that's just
the way of the world and if you don't do
that more chance that you will be
unhappier in your 40s and 50s like
statistic statistically i mean that's a
guess right but i guess i'm saying
statistically i can see how that makes
sense um but
you know the most important thing is
that you're sort of working towards
understanding
what makes you happy and how to spend
your time so if there is no work-life
balance there's just life
well there's also just time and that is
something that is being spent every
single day as the currency that we all
have so we've got less and less of it
every single minute so it's nice to
think more meaningfully about how you
spend it and actually
if you're someone like me like i love my
work i love work i love the things i do
i love all the different challenges that
come with being an entrepreneur every
minute spent there is great joy right
i've got friends who
don't love work but they love their
family time and going on holidays and
all that stuff so therefore they really
appreciate the work that they do that
they can do between nine and five
um and put in you know the minimum but
reasonable amount of effort to get the
things that they want and they're just
as happy as i am we just have we just
both understand ourselves you know i
think that's the really important thing
like i wouldn't be happy doing their
thing they wouldn't be happy doing my
thing but we're both as happy as each
other oh because we've stuck we found
the way to make our lives work for us on
on this podcast i imagine the youtube
channel there's a lot of people in their
teens and twenties uh a few people in
their 30s and older but like mostly
teens and 20s listening to this stuff
and
when people talk about
purpose and
finding your coding and all that jazz
and i think you touched on it just now
where it's like it's it's very easy to
say that oh focus on your purpose but
when you're young and you're just kind
of finishing school or starting
university or trying to get your first
job
it's like if you had that requirement
that you have to find what's purposeful
and meaningful and what your values are
and only do work that aligns with that
that would become paralytic to the point
that you wouldn't go anywhere and you'd
end up broken homeless and stuff
how yeah how how do you how would you
advise like a younger person let's say
someone in there like let's say early to
mid 20s just going into their first job
potentially wanting to have an impact on
the world like young people seem to do
these days yeah yeah um but also you
know it is the way of the world that you
might have to get a job in admit that
you just don't like for sure
um
well everyone will give different advice
the most important thing is listen to
varied advice from varied people that
you respect um you might not respect me
for whatever reason and i think that's
absolutely valid and fair so find people
that you respect the values of or the
journey that they're on and the messages
that they share
for me
you know the way that i like to live my
life um and i have this chat with my
wife a little bit because she's um you
know different in this sense but i like
to think of things that strong opinions
loosely held
my wife has strong opinions strongly
held
but i'm strong opinions loosely held and
i guess also the other side that is like
i'm not a dogmatic person i'm very up
for changing my mind um and actually one
of the things i think why i really like
working in science even though i'm not a
scientist like i love it because science
is loads of pure facts
that completely
um
go against the last person's facts and
then can be completely disproven again
by new persons facts and everyone is
just respectful about the fact that this
is the current science and the facts
until something better comes along and
disproves it and displaces it and
there's new science and new evidence the
reason i'm saying this is because i
think a lot of people are extremely
dogmatic they take a point of view this
comes back to identity they take a point
of view about who they are what they are
and how they want to present themselves
the world i am a youtuber i am a
podcaster i am an entrepreneur these are
labels um and labels can get you really
stuck on the person that you think you
are and the other people and that you'd
like other people to perceive you and
you sort of go about like repeating it a
lot you know i did like a lot of time in
clubhouse like earlier this year when my
wife had morning sickness because she
couldn't go anywhere near me so i was
like thank god i speak to some friends i
was in lockdown so i'll just go make
some random friends on on a voice app
and there was this kid there he was like
17 years old and was a life life coach
oh okay interesting and i was just like
i had really good chats with him lovely
guy i really liked him but you know i
can't help but just like be skeptical
like you can't be a life coach at 17.
like i mean you can you totally can i
don't let me like get in the way of your
dream said speech and i wasn't telling
him that you can't yes but like i don't
think i can be a life coach at 35. yeah
um you know life is there to be lived
you have to understand different
people's experiences there's so many
different types of experiences like one
of the best things you can do in your
life is go traveling into other cultures
like we both live in england um it is a
first world country i know that you
obviously are from third world countries
where you have african roots as well but
you know the reality is like you know
you've lived most of your life in
england so you've had a first world
upbringing as have i
go to third world country go to favela
go to a shanty town go see how people in
these communities live that's a great
opportunity to think differently about
the world for starters
secondly
um
i
yeah i think
pragmatism
is hugely underrated so what i mean by
that is you know when you're thinking
about your purpose i said earlier we're
talking about purpose purpose can change
so one of the
most
terrifying things is people would like
having to decide like what is this thing
that i'm defining myself as because
it'll be me forever that's not true we
changed like every few years like i've
changed i've had multiple personalities
over multiple years different things
interest me at different times i can't
believe the kind of things that interest
me now that don't them you know i i
ten years ago i couldn't even imagine
not wanting to go raving every week like
i couldn't imagine that like i loved
going out i loved going clubbing i went
to every festival in europe go to
burning man every year like all of these
things like absolutely love that and i'm
just less interested in that now and
that means i'm a different person
it doesn't mean anything like i don't
judge myself on it it just means i'm
like learning to listen into the person
i'm developing
um into like sort of day by day and so
right now
you know i'm an entrepreneur all right
and that's a label but maybe
in 10 years maybe i will be an author
it's a different label so to speak right
um i think the this
um big p purpose
the young people try and search for my
the best advice i have is like don't
start looking now life is for exploring
um best advice i think i can offer to
young people is to get really good
experience in various different
industries and various different spaces
so you can learn what you like i
literally did a linkedin post this
morning about um
this guy hoss that i used to employ so i
found this guy on upwork 16 year old kid
on upwork when i started my podcast
secret leaders
five dollars an hour i just needed some
help found a gun up whatever right
really really good really helpful
absolutely loved it when i started
researching new industries i wanted to
do i was learning about like brain
nutrients etc you know i got this guy on
upwork to help me a little bit as well
um
and we'd never really spoken like we're
all doing this over upwork and email
right i was like go research these
papers like tell me the summary of the
findings i'll do this
etc um the more we start working
together the more i'm like listen i'm
starting this company heights be really
helpful to have you like you know
helping out etc i'll save you a long
story short um he
like he was from this tiny town in
morocco um
really smart kid like was really just
like keen to learn everything as much as
possible so his attitude to me was
constantly like tell me what else you
want always learn this learn that no
problem do a loom do a youtube video
i'll figure out how to work all these
things out um
in the end hotspot is just like
you know a linchpin in starting heights
he was like mvp mostly
um ever like everyone that we were
employing full-time we tried to employ
him full time and he was like actually i
really want to go to university like my
dream has always been to go to
university then do an engineering
master's and like this is what i want to
do with my life and so get this amazing
email the reason i bring this up there's
an amazing email last week um from hoss
who basically said um you know you guys
have changed my life me and joel my
co-founder because you gave me all of
the opportunities you know also we moved
them from five dollars to something
reasonable right we're like look we're
going to treat you like you're in london
i'm going to pay you like 10 pounds an
hour instead and like just like you know
which is for an 18 year old at that
point like super good um we helped him
get to university he did all of his
recommendation letters helped him get
into university he just got the masters
in engineering that he wanted at his
first choice
you know and it's like oh that's amazing
it's amazing but the kid is like 21
right
20 or 21 now um he already has like four
years professional working experience
with an entrepreneur um i literally
couldn't possibly imagine a single task
that he couldn't outperform me on but
just to do in general um
anytime he wants a glowing
recommendation from me or my co-founder
he gets it but he's also now got
university experience behind him he's
doing a masters he has professional
experience he's 21. from his tiny town
in morocco and all he wants to do is get
out of morocco and go study in france
that was his dream he found a way to do
his dream to like live his dream and be
doing it right now
with a lot of different life experience
if you think about all of these
different things um because he had an
amazing attitude right so his
mindset was 100 based on i know that i
want a better education i know that i
want to get out of morocco i know i want
to get to france i know that these are
the things i want and i have some idea
of how i'm going to get there
ultimately the way that i'll achieve it
is
by turning up every day with a can-do
attitude and there's nothing i can't
learn and i really believe that i don't
think there's anything that anyone can't
learn we have these narratives about
ourselves like i do like you know i'm
not good at maths i could learn how to
be better at maths i just choose not to
um but like we all have these like
self-limiting beliefs of things we can't
do or won't do or whatever and i look at
hearts and i think like at 21 this kid
has like
a decade of experience that most people
just sort of laser out on not doing so
my advice to young people is just be
more like horse take opportunities
when you get an opportunity from someone
it you know as the employer
and you're an employer you know the
difference between someone who 10x is
your expectation level or not some
people just turn up and do the job some
people do the job know fast and show you
how they could have done the job better
and those people
are the ones who are going to win at
life
um i think hos is just such a good
example of like how other young people
should be thinking about things right
his purpose
you know isn't set i don't think if i
ask him what his purpose is he'd have
any idea whatsoever but he knows he just
wants to um you know provide value and
learn and that mindset of just like
wanting to learn is the thing that's
going to help him find his purpose at
the right time hmm nice be more like
be more hot
how do you think about money
especially in the context of we all need
some way of making money to sustain
ourselves in the world
uh for a lot of us that is our job
um
and for a lot of us that job is not also
the thing that brings us fulfillment joy
meaning connection love belonging fun uh
all of these expectations that we young
people now have on our jobs where back
in the day you know 50 years ago like
it's a job it makes you money and then
you totally enjoy your family life in
the evenings how how do you think about
money as like a serial entrepreneur like
my new father all of the experiences
you've had as a spiritual hippie kind of
guy yeah
it's a very poignant question for me
right now um i think as the father
because um
i
honestly honestly honestly never cared
about money um ever
um to my detriment
i'm not money motivated is the point
uh and that's a good and bad thing for
sure um
you know it's not great for investors to
hear that you're not that money
motivated right but like you have this
vision of the company that you want to
be but like inherently
not just
there are things that just interest me
so much more than money um
and actually interestingly i recently
came into some money um one of my
investments did really well i got a
payout
um timing was impeccable about a month
ago so just before my daughter was born
and i realized for the first time like
you know i had some money in my bank
account for the first time ever and i
suddenly realized oh
i suddenly i'm like you know what do i
do with this money right i'm like i'm
going to invest some of it you know i
did some nfts and some crypto
public stock markets and all this stuff
but i'm like you know
what do i know you know i'm selling a
flat i'm buying a house so i actually
have like big overheads coming and all
this stuff but you know fundamentally i
sort of sat there i'm like
what do i do with this money
and i realize
that
partly not caring about money is not
having money
so interestingly
like as in my personal experience i'm
not saying like philosophically for
anyone i have not sat and thought about
this too much but for me i realized like
having never had money you know my
salaries as an entrepreneur have been
pitiful um 10 years in the business um
as in 10 years as an entrepreneur at
this point um my salaries were and i'm
always really open about this you know
my salaries are literally
zero first year 12k second year 24 for
like the next two or three years um you
know i moved back in with my mom and did
all of these things right so
um
there's no money to spend right like
nothing um
anyway the point being that whenever
i've had money i've actually also
invested it so i've invested in tons of
startups which is a very illiquid liquid
illiquid asset class as you know um but
i believe in backing people and i get
much more enjoyment about helping other
people build their dreams it's a
personal thing like you know throwing
money into some stocks that could go up
or down is just so distant um and i love
building relationships i love brand
stories i love creatives um so i love
the idea that you can work with them to
help whatever way that is right maybe
that's your money maybe it's just
getting an investor update i think it's
cool to be part of that um but yeah so
anytime i've had money i've basically
given it to another entrepreneur and
invested in their company so always on
this sort of cycle and now recently like
you know what do i think about money um
i guess suddenly very differently which
is that i realized that
you know new paradigm shift as a parent
um the money isn't actually about me and
again this like comes back to the is not
about you thing um constant reminder
that it's not about you is really
helpful so suddenly you have this uh
responsibility in your life that is
someone else um
they are apparently not that cheap um
kids
i'm i'm yet to discover directly how
expensive but you know start stop you
know the little starter kit has been
quite expensive for sure yeah um
and so
you know you do start to think about um
the fact that money isn't all to be
spent some of it needs to be invested
some of it needs to be taken care of for
other people um so yeah i guess i don't
really have like a like a particularly
philosophical point of view on it only
that i think i've shifted from someone
who doesn't care about money to actually
i do care about money um but the things
that i care about haven't really changed
so i still invest in lots of startups um
first thing i did
i mean literally first thing i did when
i got my my payout was invested in three
startups that i wanted to rise and i
i've been wanting to i just didn't have
the money to and i i did the second that
i could because firstly i believe in
them right i happen to think that
investing is the best way to make money
that's just my personal belief and from
what i've seen um
you know i
uh
very hard
to
be on a linear career and you know even
entrepreneurship can be quite a linear
career sometimes
um very hard to sort of be on that and
suddenly 10x one day to the next right
hard to be at 50k salary one year and
500k the next year that's hard but it is
not that hard to technically invest 50k
and get 500k back in a year that's
possible so when you look at things on a
very uh like basic level like that
investing which is like quite high risk
extremely high risk and fairness most of
it the kind that i like to do um you
know the reality is you think about it
and actually um
realize that
my
career
isn't necessarily the i think my career
is the long-term way that i hope to make
money okay and i expect to make money
but in the shorter term you know
there's only so much you can do as an
entrepreneur as well you know you're
like running a company um you can't be
taking money out of it i mean this is
like mystical thing that people actually
imagine which is so different from
reality which is oh you're the founder
of like a you know 50 million pound
company like you must be rich yeah and
you're like oh god no like i just
literally have some shares
i just none of that is liquid so
i think the reality is whenever i get an
opportunity to invest in other people or
or you know a wide variety of investment
opportunities that's where i put my
money i know you've done quite a lot of
stuff on investing as well so um i know
but doubled down yeah yeah but not too
much startup investing no i think
heights is the fourth or fifth stop that
i've invested in i always feel a bit a
bit weird about it because um why
i feel weird about it because
i always worry about like how can i
actually add value um
but do you think like for most investors
like two million youtube subscribers
there's a lot more value add than what a
lot of investors actually are yeah i
don't know what other investors offer
and and so i think
well well i could make i could make a
youtube video for two to two million
subscribers
you're talking about why i like it yeah
but
right but there are different ways that
people add value you have an audience
audiences value some people have insight
insight is value i mean value is not
like it is not on a linear spectrum
right because that's like a a lovely
smorgasbord of things that people can
offer you you know if you're um a
nutrition professional you might have an
opinion that's value there's so many
different ways yeah but um yours is a
very like clear-cut obvious way which is
that um you know at the end of the day
if i think about it as a as the
entrepreneur you know the reason heights
excites me so much is because
like somehow my co-founder and i happen
to stumble across a space
where the science is there to back it up
so we don't have to create anything
completely new we've compounded
different things together in a new way
so a brain first supplement you know by
choosing nutrients that have the
scientific paper behind them
literally providing evidence
with none of the market awareness so
there's not many things on earth really
if you think about it there aren't new
compounds or new inventions that you can
literally say the evidence is all there
just no one's done a really good job of
putting it together and marketing it um
the concept that we have which is like
which is brain care right so literally
the idea behind brain care is if you
take care of your brain every single day
according to science and reality it will
improve your energy it will improve your
sleep your focus your productivity all
of those things plus you won't hopefully
get to the downside of mental health
like the insomnia the like you know the
negative effects but if you are at the
negative side of the spectrum you can
get back to baseline and from baseline
reach your height hence the name
that's the point of the product but
there is no market awareness of that
right people do not know that nutrition
is a part of this space so
if you go to a remote town in africa or
you know
a favela in brazil and ask people how to
look after their brains or their mental
health they will all say the same thing
i was in even the niche as much as the
well um you know as much as anyone in
london you know maybe therapy speaking
to friends go outside for a walk you
know these are things that we understand
nutrition won't come up it doesn't
matter how sophisticated you are like
nutrition supplementation vitamins that
can impact
emotions and things like sleep and
energy it doesn't come up people don't
think about it but it's scientifically
true so that is an unbelievable platform
to raise awareness in and you know again
like i say it's it's
so exciting as an entrepreneur because
it is unusual to find a niche like that
that people aren't playing in yet but i
think it will be a huge category but to
find a space where people aren't playing
in yet where
everyone is essentially your customer
because they have brains but sort of the
entry point that they become interested
in is it sleep is it energy is it this
or is it that you know that's that's the
challenging bit um so you find people
like yourself where your audience is
more interested in productivity right
and and essentially achieving more right
that's the most important part of your
message is like you know unlock your own
ability
and
that'll be your message for your
audience and that is like exactly the
thing that can like help us usually
because we get to learn from you as well
we get to learn how do you speak to your
audience and how do they respond to this
stuff because
you know the job that the entrepreneur
has to do is great product development
so you know without harking on too much
that's the number one rated supplement
on trustpilot now full stop so proof is
in the pudding that is literally trust
pilot biggest review engine in the world
and we're number one and we're only a
year and a half old so
the proof is in the pudding and how the
product makes people feel just no one
knows about it so that's like an
unbelievable opportunity or value add
for an audience owner interesting
um one thing i was gonna ask about like
regarding this yes
so i've been taking it for about a week
or two now judging by the the size of
this yeah it looks like a um
what are you supposed to feel like yeah
i i don't feel any real different any
noticeable difference in my like
energy level like what's the time scale
and yeah what should i expect and yeah
so this all depends on really three
things yeah so one is um where you are
today yeah so
if you are like at your baseline healthy
look after yourself
go to the gym all of the things right
and generally like a really good diet
then
the increment levels are
according to the science anyway so we'll
use the science on this between one and
three months so much longer period right
and this is actually one of the really
interesting things like a with
subscription because we're not looking
for quick fix we're not trying to tell
you that this is a limitless pill this
is not an overnight thing you're not
going to get a buzz you will notice an
overall improvement in energy levels
like notably an overall improvement in
energy levels
productivity and focus are two things
that people say a lot but focus seems to
be like actually quite a big one okay um
which is the ability when working to
focus on work um um it like i say if you
come in like you're already healthy
that's a one to three months kind of
timeline which is
the other really interesting thing which
is like everyone wants results today no
one's willing to do anything for the
long term but as you know
sadly that's counter intuitive so lots
of people pick up new habits and then
drop them and then they wonder why they
don't work and the really interesting
thing that we have to unlock at heights
somehow is we don't let anyone
everything's a subscription basis with
us you can't just buy it once you can't
just buy in the shop you can't do any of
that stuff right it's a subscription
product most popular version of it is
three month um almost all of the results
so the trust pilot reviews etc are all
post three months so it's people
actually giving this a go because
they're serious about doing something
for the long term
and then they sustain like our retention
metrics are crazy um and you only get
that if your product's good especially
in supplements where drop-off is awful
so
that's very common the flip side by the
way is if you're currently struggling so
like let's say you are struggling with
sleep or anxiety or i mean a lot of
different you know can even be
depression by the way like you know
there's a lot of different mental
problems mental health problems that are
below the baseline as i like to call
them um if you're currently suffering
with one of those it is very common and
also by the way if you have like a um
actual neurological um like diagnosed
system so uh adhd or bipolar you know
any of these kinds of things um
usually the impact is within one month
and then the most interesting one is
vegans um people who are completely
plant-based but also a lot of
vegetarians they'll usually feel it
within one to two weeks
um and that comes down to the nutrients
they're usually lacking from their diets
and i can say that because i am one so
it's not like consulting anyone it just
seems to be a fact um um that is just
because you're missing out on certain
diet as you are on any diet right if
you're doing the cave fan diet if you're
doing a vegan diet whatever you choose
to do that isn't just broad spectrum
spectrum you'll be missing something so
those are the real anomalies the reviews
that we get
always we have this like internal joke
basically if we see a review go up in
one to two weeks or someone emailing us
to tell us about how amazing it all is
etc we're like literally they've got a
vegan or they are a vegan or they're
currently got some kind of issue let's
let's find out and they always do and
they always are always interesting so
it is all about where your current
lifestyle and circumstance starts you at
right now um and yeah i mean there's a
thing where you come back to like my
story when i had um insomnia and anxiety
um
what she prescribed for me worked
like super fast within a blueberry
extract yeah the bits yeah within a week
what does that work like what the hell
is blueberry so so so to give you an
idea on these things so um to like break
it down into the science so your brain
is 60 fat 90 fat is one compound which
is dha so dha omega 3 is basically the
main building block of your brain so if
you think about it like a house um got
foundations you've got all of these
things and let's say the dha the bricks
um if you think about a house with
bricks you can remove as many bricks as
you like and you can put back in
polystyrene here and there right but
after a while it's going to start to
collapse and that's kind of what happens
with your brain if you starve it of dha
vegans do not get enough dha you have to
supplement dha if you're a vegan it is a
fact all vegans will tell you i mean a
lot of them will but that's not true you
get omega-3s from ala from um
from plants
ala very rarely actually translates into
dha um so i won't get into the whole
scientific process i'm not a
nutritionist i don't like to even like i
know i don't like to like overstep my
boundaries but the reality is very hard
to convert ala into dha so you have to
supplement it from algae for example so
most and up deficient in dha number one
compound in your brain so the fact that
it starts to have
an impact on your health is not
surprising so what was happening to me
as an example is i was starting to get
warning signs right my
building my house was on fire
and i was ignoring it
and you know it starts off with not
being able to sleep very well then it
goes into full-blown insomnia and then
it's chronic anxiety and these new fires
are coming on every single day until i
have like you know when i start going
through a process of elimination am i
meditating am i seeing a sleep therapist
am i going to the doctor am i doing all
of these things in the end i go to a
dietitian here's something it calms it
down
dozes the fire out right and and
suddenly on my okay i'm back to normal
right so my brain is literally giving me
warning signs by symptoms mental health
symptoms that says you're not okay
that's the dha side the b vitamins is
actually energy regulation so i'm sure
you're like familiar like even baroque
and stuff and actually you'll have
noticed your urine when taking it right
it goes a bit more yellow and that's
because it's riboflavin which is yeah
yeah
so that's like totally normal it's
exactly the same as baraka but basically
it's just a high level of concentration
of b vitamins which by the way is
amazing for so many things including for
long-term brain health and for
productivity um
b vitamin complex is all about energy
regulation so when you've got insomnia
for example very irregular energy
regulations so b vitamin high dose very
important and then the blueberry extract
the one that got you peaked your
interest which is in heights so for the
equivalent of 25 blueberries every
single day in a double dose of heights
so double dose being two pills so every
day it's two pills um so one dose two
capsules um um
25 blueberries in the form of
anthocyanins which is the extract
and what it actually is is an
antioxidant and what that does is it
cleans the lymphatic system of your
brain whilst you sleep so
you know our chief science officer dr
tara swartz she has this lovely analogy
she uses which is like it's like putting
your brain through a car wash every
evening
so it's cleaning out the system um of
your brain whilst you're sleeping where
junk and dust and all these sort of
things will gunk basically will will um
pile up in your brain and the
antioxidants will clean it out that's
why blueberry extract it just happens to
be the highest form and highest quality
and blueberries by the way have like
phenomenally interesting um
neuroscientific advantages
i
even though i take heights i eat about
you know 15 to 20 blueberries every
single day on top of that as well most
interesting scientific study is um
there's 13
um so yeah i think 13 and 15 year olds
doing their exams and the ones that took
blueberries before their exams same day
blueberries before their exams much
better grades than the people who didn't
because it's insane but it's a really
well known scientific study it's so
funny yeah um so there are like lots of
stories about how blueberries are
incredible for your brain but you know
actually using 25 blueberries is quite
expensive as well so you know that will
cost two pound fifty three pounds a day
um to do that so even though it's good
for you and obviously do advocate eating
like healthy food as much as possible um
most people don't and this is the thing
like our main message at heights is
actually we'll tell you all of the whole
point of heights as a brand is come join
our newsletter listen to our braincare
podcast we have a podcast it's 15
minutes every episode with different
academic or scientific expert it's all
super snappy i write a newsletter every
single week which is how the company
started 140 episodes in now um every
sunday two to three minute read max
but our whole job is to help you
understand how to take care of your
brain according to science
if you can get that in your whole food
diet you don't need the supplement then
don't take it right definitely have the
best diet ever hugely encourage it but
according to again studies and the
science in the uk um 99 of us do not get
anywhere near that requirement so this
is using something called the mind diet
which will obviously be very familiar
with basically a mediterranean diet and
very high in fats and fish and you know
all sorts but you could substitute that
out for algae or whatever if you wanted
to the reality is most of us just do not
eat this way um we are very dire we
might even deliver whatever it is right
like live normal lives with busy people
so heights is literally the most simple
like guaranteed way of making sure that
you're giving your brain the nutrients
that it's meant to have every single day
according to science to stop any of the
downside effects happening but also over
the long time compound the positive
effects and you can get all of it from
food yeah so definitely encourage that
first and foremost but i tried it so
this is the other thing that's gonna say
before we started this i tried i thought
i was gonna do like a meal delivery
service type thing of like brain food
and stuff but my god it was expensive
and tiring
and i'm a bad cook that didn't help yeah
i mean i've i've tried the mediterranean
diet so many times and lasted like one
day yeah it's hard to keep up it's just
too much effort like i want to get
delivery i want to go for dinner with
the boys that kind of thing exactly
okay interesting um
okay i feel like we could talk about
this forever um but
i wanna i wanna have lunch with you now
yeah i'm hungry so we have a video for
another time video for another time uh
we have a handful of uh questions from
instagram okay um which we can just sort
of do as rapid fire but go for it
so uh harry blogs says how do you deal
with negative thoughts if i say the
wrong thing in a social situation i
spend tons of time thinking about it
afterwards oh it's great question um so
there's a great guy i interviewed on
braincare podcast called dr daniel arman
and he has a saying called ants which is
automatic negative thoughts um basically
our we have a negativity bias right
psychologically for whatever reason well
there is a reason we have a negativity
bias because we're born to protect
ourselves right so when we grew up and
we're in the jungle and all this stuff
you know ultimately got to protect
ourselves we've got to look for threats
so we are naturally hardwired to think
negatively to be negative etc um
how do i deal with negative thoughts
awareness
so the most important
i you know i believe one of the most
important realizations i've had i've had
this from my oscar but i've had it from
reading plenty of books after the fact
is that i am not my thoughts
so
you know really accessible spiritual
book that i think is fantastic is a book
called um the untethered soul
it's by an ex-entrepreneur
it's not woo-woo language totally
accessible really easy to read good fun
and in it the author michael singer
talks about
there was a noisy roommate inside your
head talking absolutely garbage to you
all the time right and you basically
live with a maniac you live with this
irritating voice inside your head and
it is driving you wild and for whatever
reason this guy is a nut case and
everyone lives with him right every
single person has this like absolute nut
case inside your head and he's feeding
you [ __ ] all the time so as soon as you
like literally part of spirituality as
well as like this awareness
of like this duality two voices inside
your head one is you
the awareness of like oh who is that
where's that coming from and why is that
being said and the other is the constant
chatter that constant chat is almost
always negative so and if you don't stop
and listen and think where's that coming
from and why
then it will just keep on going so
what helps me is this awareness that i
am not my thoughts
sick just put it on audible uh link in
the video description audible if anyone
wants to check it out um maria says do
you have any tips from men about talking
about their feelings oh that's
interesting yeah it's interesting isn't
it because yeah men do find it hard to
speak about their feelings whereas um
you know for me masculine masculinity
is
such a loaded concept like i find myself
like
it's interesting you know i with my wife
for example we have sort of gender role
reversals and that like a lot of my
behaviors are like the feminine
stereotype and hers the masculine
stereotype but um
you know giving other men i think the
first thing is like uh men giving other
men advice on how to be sensitive
probably is the first way to not get to
open up and do it this is the challenge
and i do think that there's a rot a
really great role for role models for
male role models to be more welcoming
and open about speaking about our
feelings because it's this weird like
macho thing like as in you know
we're human so male or female whatever
we're human and humans have emotions
right this is the stuff that happens
psychologically inside our brains one
way or another and sadly like when you
don't express those emotions you don't
share how you feel and you don't share
why you're feeling that way and you are
you're unable to connect with someone
else and that lack of connection could
lead to a sense of loneliness and then
that loneliness can lead to bitterness
and can release a personal confusion
about where you are on earth so i think
um you know i don't necessarily have a
book although i suppose if i was to
recommend one there's a great book
called lost connections by johann harry
um it's it's more a book on like the
story of mental health and depression to
an extent but it is a great story as
well just like on
how much humans need connection and one
of the ways that we can connect best is
by being vulnerable right there's only
so much you can learn from someone that
talks about how great they are all the
time like that kind of showboating is
interesting as well you look at like
instagram right like you know a few
years ago like most interesting content
is just like hot girls bikinis that kind
of stuff now it's actually like people
opening up and talking about how they
feel and that's just like vulnerability
yeah yeah exactly
like also just bored of all the surface
level stuff like i'm not as amazing as
you doesn't really make me like you as
much as like oh you're a real person
with real feelings wicked me too yeah
one thing that i've i've noticed this
issue recently where i
struggled to talk about my feelings um
and i always thought it was because i
just didn't have the feelings and i was
like well you know i'm generally a stoic
guy i've drunk the kool-aid for a while
yeah and so
for me like when i describe something as
like making me feel bad it's like you
know i've got my bracelet level of
tranquility and this is like a minor a
minor blip
um and what my housemate was encouraging
me to do is be like okay you know stop
thinking that you're going to get like a
blip to like a negative 10 because
that's never going to happen for you but
just like kind of expand the scale out
so when when you have a minor blip
that's like a pretty significant event
for you and i'm trying to describe how
you're feeling and at that point i'd be
like well uh
i don't have a word um but what i find
useful is to just be like you know what
i'm i'm i'm just gonna try and try and
just talk about how i'm feeling without
feeling as if i need to be able to
describe it with a single like in a
succinct tweetable yeah 140 character
yeah yeah and then i found that one time
oh i'm i'm feeling a bit of this because
a little bit of a bit of a bit of that
like it became kind of rambly but that
really helped me to talk about my
feelings without feeling that pressure
to be able to say i am feeling anxious
right now because i was like what does
that even mean i don't know
i'm feeling scared i'm feeling stressed
it's like well no i'm kind of feeling a
little bit of this because
that i found that expanding it out to
not a tweet found it really
much more helpful for me to talk about
my feelings yeah and also labeling your
feelings is a really like it's a
well-known practice it's very helpful
right so being able to say like i am
feeling angry yeah
is in a way like very similar to the
last answer it's the awareness of like
you're a human being you're going
through that emotion you're able to
speak about it you know and as soon as
it's out you realize that actually it
becomes quite other
literally saying i am angry has made
that feeling into an object outside of
you so now you're looking at it and
you're like well i guess that's not so
scary yeah
nice um two more questions so hussain
says how do you organize your life
uh or three more yeah how how do you
organize your life what are your daily
practices um yeah um okay so my daily
practices and i'm like i do mix this up
timing wise um
so
i always wake up and do the same morning
practice right so i say grateful for
waking up today think about my intention
that's like first 30 seconds take my
heights drink some water
um now you know
kiss the baby change the baby all that
stuff that needs to happen at that
moment like whatever um then i'll either
do
so usually what i'll do is go for a walk
um and go for a walk is like my number
one life hack for every right so i do
walking meetings i do walking zooms
walking everything i do walking and if i
don't have them i will do like audible
or a podcast or sometimes i just take my
headphones out and i just like a walking
meditation and by that all i mean is
literally just like you know i'm not
trying to clear my mind i'm just trying
to observe the things around me um and
in so doing it clears my mind so
that's like i do an hour and a half
every day
of a walk
and um i think that's one of the
benefits of like the the pandemic is
like i've got team stand-up whatever
like they i mean everyone is used to me
being on a walk the whole time now
anyway um so that's like uh probably
takes me up to about 10 a.m
um
then i will do an hour of work almost
always and then at 11 i will do either
the peloton or yoga
um then i will shower then i'll make
lunch for my wife my baby etc etc and
the afternoon tends to be where i'm more
like more like focused productive time
so
um
say i finish work i mean you know
i'd like to pretend that i finished work
early but you know whatever i've got a
new routine as well i'm trying to figure
out that's the interesting thing right
you're asking this question like at a
time when i kind of
i'm going to have to sort of feel out
how this goes um
usually i'll do podcast recording six
till seven seven thirty um so i've got
two podcasts um
which is like three episodes a week so
it's quite a lot so i need to make sure
that i like stay on that schedule quite
well um
and at 7 30ish i will either have dinner
or make dinner depending on whose turn
is obviously the new father it's more my
turn um and then almost always every
single night i just hang out with my
wife um so i don't really tend to work
maybe i'll do some emails on my phone
etc but like in reality that's what i'm
doing and then before i go to bed every
single night same thing i do 10 minutes
so i tried to fit in 10 minutes of
meditation during the day but i usually
mess it up like i'm usually too busy or
some kind of personal excuse i'm trying
to get better at but it's what happens
um i'll always do 10 minutes of
meditation before bed um because i know
that i can guarantee that i will be in
my bed that i can listen to a calm or
insight time or something like that or
waking up i like a lot as well um
so i will do 10 minutes of meditation
before bed and i will always do my
gratitude journal so this is one of the
ways that the brain care journal came
out like a whole other topic another
time is marriage okrs which like
literally very interesting yeah hold on
the topic for another yeah
for another time marriage okay with your
wife okay um which like my evening
practice plays into a lot so i do like a
habit tracker what the things i did
today um
so that i have some awareness as well
like did i actually do my brain care
habits like is that like again like
going for a walk drinking enough water
like these are all things i do for my
brain because if it's good for my brain
it's good for my body and therefore i'm
going to be happy productive etc um but
also um you know i make sure that we do
three things that went well today
it's the usual gratitude practice from
martin seligman so three things that
went well
um
one thing i manifest
so quite often it's something for
someone else you know i hope my friends
you know exams go well whatever the
thing is right like you just it gives
you a great moment to think about who's
in your circle and who you want to pray
for something good for
um
one
um oh yeah let's do one thing we learned
today so with my wife one thing we
taught each other
so that gets us into the habit this is
from marriage okay ours right so this is
a bit more like niche but anyway this is
like one thing that i learned today that
i want to share with my wife that i want
to teach her and it just gets us into
the process of learning something new
every single day because we know that
we're going to teach each other
something before we go to sleep um and
the final thing is what we ate today
so that keeps us on track to be like you
know have this accountability with a
partner right it's like you know we have
these sort of separate lives um but
they're together and we want to live a
long and fulfilling life together over
the long term so as long as you're
accountable on a daily basis on the
things you're grateful for what you're
learning what you're eating and how
you're spending your time and you're
comparing those sort of with actual
accountability at the end of the day
just by sharing with each other sort of
keeps you roughly on the straight and
narrow interesting that's very
interesting i have so many questions to
ask you about this while we're having
lunch um okay abe says what is one piece
of business advice you ignored and now
regret not taking oh that's a great
question i i don't ignore this now but
um the advice i always ignored before
was focus on margin
margin as in business margin as in so
when you're making a physical product
you're making a product for anyone
the inclination as an entrepreneur
sometimes people can be very price
sensitive especially with a product like
this it's a very expensive product to
make
and we're working in an industry where
everyone pedals cheap stuff so the
understanding of the quality and the
price that you should pay is way off the
mark so it's very tempting to take a
huge hit on your margin to basically
sell it at almost nothing
so what not almost nothing but almost at
the point where you're not making any
money but great advice i got and you get
this in business school or when you fail
a business which i have
if you don't look after your margin you
can't look after your customers you
can't look after um problems you can't
look after your team like it's a big
mistake that a lot of entrepreneurs make
and especially bleeding heart ones like
myself like a lot of people that go into
entrepreneurship who want to do good and
we'll do great things i don't care about
money and all these narratives and stuff
and the reality is all of those things
will limit you from being successful um
the reality is if you're choosing to be
an entrepreneur make a business your
responsibility to everyone your
customers and your team is to make sure
that you're doing it in a sustainable
way that you can grow that you found the
right price point that you can get the
best quality you can do all of the
things that align with your objectives
as a company yeah um selling the
cheapest products at the cheapest prices
that's like an amazon thing right that's
literally like one of their things
that's why they exist so great that's
that fits their business model and at
the scale they're out of billions of
customers it works but for most of us
that doesn't work and so
it's a really hard lesson i learned from
failing interesting yeah very
interesting uh and finally grace says
what's one piece of advice that you'd
give for aspiring entrepreneurs
yeah so one piece of advice um
like 100 is so obvious um like so so
obvious but is just be kind so
it is
not that they like everything comes
around i i mean obviously i believe in
karma and things like that because like
i you've been listening to me of course
i do um of course
but
it's
uncanny to me how many times being kind
to someone without even really thinking
about it has come back to 10x that
opportunity for me later right so it's
not even just like trying to say people
be kind in a spiritual sense be kind
because it's good for business be kind
to everyone you possibly can all the
time because it's great for business and
like wherever you can take the high road
so don't get involved in like pettiness
don't do stuff to like because this
person did x i'm gonna do why
like
all of those things are emotional
moments are going to come up when you're
running a business for sure um and it's
fine to have those thoughts and it's
fine to fantasize about those thoughts
but don't act on them or do them always
take the high road it's never worth it
and um and business will be good to you
back awesome dan thank you so much uh
where can people find out more about you
learn about you if they're interested
yeah so i'm at dan murray certa on all
social platforms my podcasts where i
interview other leaders as secret
leaders and our brain care podcasts if
you're into all things neuroscience and
mental health um is where you'll find
that fantastic any podcast player thanks
for coming on thanks man uh and we'll
see you later everyone thanks for
listening